good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3516
object class
safe
special containment procedures
scp-3516 is to be kept in a locked box
at site-77 when not in use for testing
both wheels of
scp-3516 are to be locked using a
standard bike lock
when using scp-3516
no protective equipment is to be issued
to the rider testing of
scp-3516 may only be done outdoors and
may not be done within 50 meters of any
essential mechanisms of the site
observers are required to stand behind a
screen of protective glass at all times
when testing scp-3516
riders of
scp-3516 are to be equipped with a metal
rod to jam between the spokes of the
front wheel in the likelihood of
superficial injuries occurring at least
one medical personnel must be present
for every test
description
scp-3516 is a red bicycle specifically
the 1982 swin predator model flame
symbols are crudely painted alongside
the body of the bicycle in acrylic paint
two spokes on the front wheel are bent
and five on the back wheel the entire
bicycle shows signs of age and wear but
still functions normally
when any human subject begins to ride
scp-3516
the anomalous abilities of
scp-3516 will activate regardless of the
current situation or speed the subject
will experience feelings of excitement
and increased levels of adrenaline
similar to those experienced when on a
roller coaster or other method of
thrill-based entertainment the subject
will also become increasingly accident
prone as time goes on with an estimated
additional 8 chance of falling off of or
crashing scp-3516
for every minute passed
90 of subjects are observed to have an
accident within 10 minutes of beginning
to ride scp-3516
it should be noted that regardless of
the severity of the crash
scp-3516 will show either minimal or no
damage experimentation is proven that it
may be damaged outside of crashes
once the subject has fallen off of or
otherwise crashed scp-3516
scp-3516's secondary ability will
manifest the severity of damage caused
to the surroundings of scp-3516
which may or may not include the rider
will be far greater than what is
normally possible from the impact with
collision speeds as low as 30 kilometers
per hour releasing upwards of 22 000
newtons
impacted objects will also show
decreased stability
breaking under forces that they would
normally withstand
the final aspect of
scp-3516's anomalous abilities concern
any injuries sustained by the rider over
the course of the crash the severity of
the injuries including those
extrapolated upon by the secondary
ability of scp-3516
is effectively inverted the wounds that
would normally be life-threatening or
fatal will instead seem to have no
effect on the subject's health and may
be easily recuperated from
small or minor wounds however will prove
to be devastating with a skinned knee
being sufficient to knock the subject
unconscious and taking weeks of intense
care to heal if the subject managed to
sustain no injuries over the course of
the crash no anomalous abilities will
activate
scp-3516 testing log
test scp-3516
subjects d-1033-4
experiment director dr sombre procedure
d-1033-4 is equipped with a bicycle
helmet and is instructed to ride
scp-3516
into a concrete wall observed impact
speed is 28 kilometers per hour
experiment is overviewed by dr sombre
results the front tire of
scp-3516 lodges 13 centimeters deep into
the wall
and d-10334 is bucked head first over
the handlebars and into the wall where
the helmet splits in two and
d-1033-4 shatters two vertebrae suffers
several skull fractures and a ruptured
trachea after eight seconds subject
stands up and complains of dizziness
full recovery is made in 20 hours after
subject is issued a single bandage and a
mild painkiller
test scp-3516-17
subjects
d-12708 experiment director researcher
pozzarelli procedure
d-12708 is instructed to ride a scp-3516
off of an 8-meter drop onto a concrete
surface
d-12708 is not issued any protective
equipment as doing so has proven futile
results upon impact
scp-3516 bounces roughly 20 meters and
injures researcher pascarelli dislodging
scp-12708 in the process the left arm
and leg of d-12708 are dislocated upon
impact
and two toes are broken
d-12708 reports reduced feelings of
discomfort and pain while injured and
during the relocation process broken
toes heal over the course of four days
notes i'm making changes to the
containment procedures one of the petals
knocked out three of my teeth
researcher pascarelli
test 3516 20 subjects
d10980 and agent
experiment director dr
procedure
d-10980 is instructed to write
scp-3516 in a straight line as she is
doing so
agent is to shoot d-10980 in the leg
with a sniper rifle results
d-10980 is successfully shot and falls
off of
scp-3516 the injuries sustained from the
crash are easily treated but the gunshot
wound shows no anomalous properties
notes this confirms that
scp-3516's effects only apply to the
injury sustained in the crash or at
least those caused by riding it shame
otherwise we could have potentially used
it to facilitate healing by purposely
injuring prior patients as stupid as
that sounds doctor
test scp-3516-21
subjects d200 339
experiment director dr
procedure
scp-239 is instructed to ride scp-3516
in a straight line while doing this they
will pass over several buried high-yield
landmines
d-239 has not been informed of the
landmines results the land mines are
successfully detonated
scp-3516 is not damaged aside from
slight degradation of the paint and d239
is blown into multiple pieces however
each individual piece of d239 did not
die and were able to be surgically
joined together again afterwards
d-239 did not show any lingering
anomalous abilities
notes that was gruesome but easily the
most impressive demonstration of
scp-3516's abilities to date there may
not be an upper limit to the level of
damage it can invert as long as
scp-3516 is mostly responsible for
causing it even the portions of d239's
body we couldn't recover regenerated
once the rest were assembled
test scp-3516-28
subjects d-10802
experiment director researcher
procedure
d-10802 is to ride scp-3516
past a pricker bush results as the 10802
bikes past a single thorn grazes his leg
leaving a small scratch
d-10802 immediately expires
autopsy reveals the cause of death as
simultaneous cessation
of all bodily functions
notes
and here we see the opposite end of the
spectrum research
test scp-3516-33
subjects d165
experiment director researcher
procedure
d165 while writing
scp-3516 is dropped out of an airplane
at kilometers results
notes
jesus christ research
recovery
scp-3516 was brought to the foundation's
attention and subsequently recovered on
4 15 2002 when a terrorist thought to be
operating alongside
rode
scp-3516 into the middle of the freeway
resulting in
casualties and fatalities while this
normally would not have been enough to
warrant further investigation
eyewitnesses reports of a man
reattaching several severed limbs before
biking out of the crater caused by a gas
tanker exploding seemingly perfectly
unharmed field agents gave pursuit
following the trail of destruction
caused by
scp-3516's effects and
scp-3516 was eventually secured when the
rider suffered a slight scrape from a
pebble being kicked up towards their
face by the tires and subsequently
expired class c amnestics were issued to
aid in cover-up and the damage was
explained to have been caused by a
string of terrorist bombings
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargeran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
nicholas hayes
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
jaby
pure osmium
sayo diodemnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbage
longinus
carcass death aqua
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you